the Masters is a tournament that makes
Legends and while some of you may be
unfamiliar with Larry Mize that is the
status that he's achieved here Friday
playing the start of his final
competitive round at the Masters
extended a bit by the rain he'll finish
today mines actually grew up playing on
a course so close to here he could peer
through the fence on the ninth hole and
see Augusta National's feigned Amen
Corner then in 1987 Larry Mize won the
Masters the only golfer from Augusta
ever to do so we caught up with him as
he got ready to say goodbye to the
tournament that inspired it all
so you climbed up the other day on
Monday morning yeah Larry Mize has
visited the third leaderboard at Augusta
National at the start of Masters week
for nearly four decades a touchstone for
the 87 Masters champ having worked that
leaderboard before appearing on it years
ago
what was it like working this oh I was I
was loving it I mean I was a little kid
and just you know loved get to come out
here and get up here and work the
scoreboard and you know feel like you're
part of the action you know you'd worked
either the morning shift or the
afternoon shift and just to give me a
sense we climbed to the top
you've got the slots here for you know
this is the ninth hole eighth hole
seventh hole you slide the number in the
slot and put it back up and you listen
for the listen for the Ooze Oz or Roars
or whatever the kind of you know if
you're putting up a birdie for Jack
Nicklaus it'll be a big Roar for Arnold
it'd be a tremendous Roar it was an
opportunity of a lifetime for a local
kid Mize was 4
growing up in the town known for golf
he'd learned to both play and love the
game
take me back in time when you were a
little kid what do you remember about
when you first started playing golf I
remember I fell in love with the game
both my parents played okay but my dad
had the biggest impact on me I'd play
with him some and he always encouraged
me and we would chip out in the front
yard over the walkway so we would get
closest and with the Masters Tournament
being there I'd seen all those great
players you know a lot of people want to
be a doctor or a lawyer or something I
never want to do anything but play a
professional golf it was a lofty dream
but I had it
as a teenager mize's determination to
make the PGA Tour grew stronger there
were a lot of people that you know
thought I was crazy trying to get on
tour they said you're not good enough
you can't make it they're they're guys
can't make the tour that could beat you
and that just kind of fueled my fire in
1980 Larry Mize turned Pro three years
later he captured his first PGA Tour win
at the Danny Thomas Memphis classic
earning a trip home the following year
to compete at the Masters thankfully
mice had two practice rounds before the
tournament began so I went out there
Tuesday shaking in my boots trying to
tee the ball up and I'm just I can
barely get on the tee on number one and
I hook it over to ninth Fairway I'm so
nervous Wednesday I'm nervous again
barely get on the T hook it in the ninth
Fairway I mean yeah Knight Fairway again
it's like oh my gosh what am I going to
do on Thursday
but I kind of got over those Jitters a
little bit so on Thursday thank goodness
I drove it right down the middle and had
a good week but I'll never forget I was
so nervous do you think it was even more
nerve-wracking for you than anybody else
playing at the Masters because that's
also that was home well I I I feel that
way I don't know you'd have to ask the
other players that way I think it's
nerve-wracking for anybody but for a
local kid to be there yeah I think it
could be a little more yeah he's only
won one golf tournament out here on the
PGA tour
1983. in 1987 Mize was back at Augusta
National this time to make history I
think that the the key moment for me was
Saturday when I hit it in the water on
12. okay and I made about a 10 foot or
so for bogey which was huge because I
was about to play myself out of the
tournament I think that put me five
shots back
well I went on to birdie three holes
coming in to get back to even par for
the day and only be two shots back so
that was a key spot that kept me in
contention going into Sunday yeah
now at the end of the final round Mize
who was ranked 34th on the tour was
locked in a three-way tie with two of
The Game's greats Greg Norman and sevy
by esteros who already had five major
victories between them with a sudden
death format after the first playoff
hole it was down to Mize and Norman
he left it to the right it'll on the
next hole mize's second shot landed 140
feet from the pin while Norman was in
putting distance Kenny I wonder if he
was trying to swing a big hook and just
came off it obviously Greg was in a
better position than I was
um and uh I'm just trying to put it
close to the hole put the pressure back
on him
[Applause]
I hit a really good shot it came off
like I wanted to but for it to go in the
hole at that time with the timing of
everything it's pretty pretty lazy
I think that that probably says it all
well people say you know how did you
feel when you when you chipped in I went
well I think my Run and Jump and
screaming says it all I was uh totally
totally Elation there's no doubt about
it visor flying off
his wife Bonnie and nearly one-year-old
son David were there to see him win the
Green Jacket which as his custom was
presented by the previous year's winner
none other than Miz's favorite golfer
Jack Nicklaus there's the shot that we
were talking about Jack putting the
green jacket on you I was so excited I
kind of look oh I did my arms out like
that I said well maybe I need to calm
down a little bit but I was so excited I
put it on I was just like all right you
know so and while Mize has plenty of
memorabilia to remind him of that
glorious afternoon in April all the
players that played in 1987 their
signatures engraved all around the sides
and the back my name's on the front he
says he's never spent a lot of time
relishing it Augusta's sentimental
favorite son until now major
championships for most of us don't come
along very often right and you know you
really need to enjoy it I I try and
relay that to the some of the younger
guys enjoy this I mean you may win
another one you may not I don't know but
really soak it in you know watch it
enjoy it I think sometimes I tried to go
beyond it to put something alongside of
it too quickly that was probably a
mistake I made not a big deal and I just
to relive it again is a good thing is it
amazing to you because it's amazing to
me that you're still the only golfer
from Augusta to have won
it really is hopefully there'll be
someone to join me I'd sure I'd like to
see that but you know it's
it's not easy to win
it's amazing I am still the only one
and a really interesting note guys this
is the 87th Masters and he won in 87 I
asked Larry Mize if that was meant to be
and he said it was a son Robert who
actually pointed it out to him but he
said that there was sort of something in
any guess that it is meant to be because
those two did line up that way really
enjoyed spending time with him and
reminiscing with him about this one
really special
we could tell Dana
it was it was really great Dana and it's
just it's so I I it was interesting how
he finally can only kind of fully
appreciate it now I thought that was
really interesting but watching the
video of that ship I mean every time you
see it you get goosebumps I'd never seen
it before it's such a revelation to me
I'm so glad I'm so glad yeah it really
is it's one and there's so many great
finishes here that is one that you
remember over and over and over again
especially the guys that he was up
against in that moment
and that he's from Augusta Dana thank
you that was really great appreciate it